[Music]
vitomir putin's has based his personal
popularity which is the key to his
regimes legitimacy on the propaganda
narrative that looks like this the
motherland is in danger NATO is about to
attack but thank God
President Putin can protect Russia and
restore the glory of the Soviet Union so
to sustain this rhetoric what might he
do next shoot down a u.s. plane over
Syria crush a possible color revolution
in Belarus send Special Ops into Estonia
during his meeting with Putin Trump
should tell him that it couldn't
continues his dangerous policies the US
will increase the domestic political
cost of his foreign policy for starters
the legislation passed by the US Senate
would squeeze the two sources of his
country's income oil and arms exports we
can send defensive weapons to Ukraine
dramatically increase our presence on
the eastern flank of NATO and can deploy
our own cyber weapons but the Putin
begins to moderate his behavior looking
to internal reforms not outward
aggression for his regimes legitimacy
the US should be the first one to
welcome this development so what should
President Trump tell President Putin at
the g20 summit let us know in your
comments also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to subscribe
for more research and videos from AI